finally a place of rest a rare moment of
Peace for this little girl one of more
than a million Palestinians forc from
their homes as Israel bombards the Gaza
Strip some families have found shelter
at a makeshift camp in the southern city
of K
Yunis hudat was injured when an Israeli
Missile hit her home she was inside at
the time one of her daughters was killed
look at these children they like me have
been injured we were pulled from the
rubble how are we at fault my home
collapsed on me same with my daughters
and we came here to live in tents
humiliated we don't have water food or
anything we fled with only the clothes
we were
wearing those with the roof over their
heads are the lucky ones the United
Nations relief and works agency has put
up 12010 in K Unice but it's no vure
enough and offers no protection from the
ongoing air
strikes we now live like our ancestors
in
1948 we displaced from our homes just
like them we are living in tents oh
world have mercy on us we're tired we
want to truce what does Israel want we
displaced from our homes what more do
they want Israel is carrying out its
heaviest bombing campaign ever on Gaza
more intense than any of the previous
Wars its Army is determined to root out
Hamas Fighters after the armed group
attacked Southern Israel 2 weeks ago
killing 1,400
Israelis Israel has also imposed a total
blockade on Gaza cutting off Imports of
water food and fuel it's further worsen
conditions in The besiege Enclave where
most of the population is dependent on
humanitarian
Aid entire residential blocks have been
hit two or three times a day in each
strike four or five houses collapse and
40 to 50 people are killed every time we
left our houses and went to un schools
where thousands of people were crowded
into seven schools and one clinic but
even those schools were not
safe a week ago the Israeli Army issued
a mass evacuation order of 1.1 million
Palestinians living in the north of The
Enclave ahead of a major ground
offensive but even in the southern Gaza
Strip where Israeli authorities told
people to move for their own protection
it's not safe mulsum Sharif Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer